free well this is I think
I agree I think someone said this it's
not just there are definitely
whether it's one term or another but
there is then at the end of the day some
practical implication of responsibility
legal responsibility and presumably
consciousness has some moral
responsibilities or implications
attached to it not only we are conscious
and therefore we should be blamed for
doing bad things but implicit in what
Terry says at where does the animal
rights question come down here what is
the program since I don't know the
answer what should our research program
be to decide what rights we give to what
beings on the basis of how they think
the organization of the brain even
though it doesn't look like yours or
mine basically is laid out the same way
visual system doesn't have there's not a
cortex in the same sense but and the
fish makes a whole set of behavioral
decisions they're quicker they're slower
they're more automatic but you can train
fish to do interesting things they can
they obviously can learn in fact we now
know that they're they're learning by
operative capabilities is as good as
yours in mine and so in all of those
centuries no absolutely not
there's also a paper on there's also a
paper on the dimensions of personality
in fish neurotic copies and
conscientious copies all right you got
to make the distinction between agents
and patients in this case so I wouldn't
make any claim that that fishes are
moral agents or anything like it
but they're clearly I think they're
clearly more patients they suffer and my
sense is that we we always attribute
some level of moral decision when the
sufferings involved are you vegetarian
no I'm not but but I like I've killed a
lot of animals and you're okay with
killing animals in the future no no
I've stopped killing monkeys but you
know I don't eat the monkeys in
particularly buddy animals yes I do
absolutely if elijah's is morally
consistent morally consistent yet no so
here's the thing I don't think there's a
nice neat
iving line and in fact sort of like
Don's parents you know I was perfectly
okay to do monkey surgeries in which
they died at the end of the process for
years and years because I had sort of
been balancing and worrying about you
know what are the consequences one of
the good bounce the good against the bad
and the disease stuff like that I
couldn't go back to doing it so it's not
I didn't see a nice neat clear white
line that said I'm crossing this line or
not it's obviously there won't be with
them bigoli there has to be so oh yeah
yeah you have to do the best we can
right so I've never done it on
chimpanzees tonight don't think I ever
would have and would you universalize
this behavior will you make it illegal
which one you pick whichever one is most
interesting also with Pete I mean Dan I
were at an interesting conference years
ago in which we were struggling with the
problem of transplantation I'd spent my
career doing a lot of neural
transplantation about you know what
happens if I put chimpanzee neurons into
human brains honey or vice versa which
was the really interesting yes the
question is you know when do we cross a
moral line it was actually very
difficult to make that decision we we
struggled it's a whole group of us
struggled with this try to make sense of
it and I think I think that kind of
moral decision is it's there's this big
gray area
you